[موسيقى]
مساء الخير بدا عام 2016 منذ ساعات قليله
ان شاء الله يكون عام خير وبركه على الامه
العربيه وعلى الامه الاسلاميه وعلى كل
العالم مراكز الابحاث وعلماء المستقبليات
والخبراء واجهزه الاستخبارات في كل دول
العالم عاكفه على دراسه 2016 وما قد يحمله
الى العالم من مفاجات او من ورات في
نزاعات قائمه بالفعل وبيدرسوا منذ شهور
يعني من 2015 ايه هي الاحداث اللي ممكن
تتطور وتتحول الى صراعات كبيره او تتحول
الى حروب ضخمه تقود العالم الى ضمار كبير
والحقيقه ان في العالم العربي من الملفات
دي كتير او ملفات خارج العالم العربي قد
تؤثر علينا بشكل كبير يعني طوال عام 2015
واظن ان في 2016 في في ملفات كانت وما
زالت محل اهتمام كبير ومسيطره على كل
الاحداث وكل عناوين الصحف ووسائل الاعلام
ابرزها واكثرها اهميه النزاع في سوريا
وتطورات الحرب على داعش ومستقبل داعش
الملفين دول ملفين مهمين جدا ما فيش خلاف
عليهم ان كانوا الاكثر اهميه في 2015 وسوف
يظلان يحتفظان بنفس الاهميه في
2016 ازاي ممكن يتطوروا في 2016 في عشرات
علامات الاستفهام عليهم وفي اكثر من
سيناريو لتطور الحرب لتطور الاوضاع في
سوريا وكذلك تطور الحرب على داعش لكن قبل
ما نتكلم على هذه السيناريوهات هل هم دول
بس الملفين اللي ممكن يمثلوا اهميه خاصه
في 2016 الحقيقه لا في اكثر من ملف اخر
يستحق الاهتمام وقد يتحول الى الاولويه
رقم واحد في العام القادم وقد يؤدي الى مش
بس بس صراع اقليمي ولكن صراع اكثر من
الصراع الاقليمي يعني صراع عالمي افتكروا
ان احنا عندنا عدد من الملفات ما زالت رغم
اهميتها منسيه او لا تحظى بنفس الاهتمام
ربما واحد من هذه الملفات وطبعا الحرب في
اليمن الحرب في اليمن في اهتمام بيه لكن
لم يحظى بنفس الاهتمام اللي حظى به الصراع
في
سوريا الحرب اللي في اليمن اللي بدات في
26 مارس لما قررت السعوديه وتسع دول اخرى
حليفه معها انضمت اليها زي الامارات وزي
قطر وزي مصر والسودان وغيرهم ينضموا
للسعوديه لتوجيه ضربه الى الحوثيين بدات
كعمليه عسكريه ارادت الرياض منها ان يكون
حرب سريعه تعيد للرئيس اليمني الاسبق علي
عبد الله صالح والى الحو والحوثيين الى
صوابهم وتدفعهم الى الجلوس على مائده
المفاوضات لكن الحرب اللي كان المفروض ان
هي تبقى حرب قصيره استمرت 10 شهور وما زال
نهايتها لا يبدو في الافق القريب وادت
كانت احد اسباب الاستنزاف للاقتصاد
السعودي اللي خسر في عده شهور اكثر من 70
مليار دولار ودفع السعوديه ان تنفق ارقام
غير مسبوقه على التسلح بحيث انها اصبحت
ثالث او رابع اكبر مشتري للسلاح في العالم
واجمال السلاح اللي اشترته السعوديه
والامارات في 2015 اللي انتهت من عده
ساعات حوالي 9.8 مليار دولار وده رقم ضخم
جدا ايه اللي ممكن يحصل التطور اللي ممكن
يحصل في حرب اليمن عليه علامات استفهام
كتيره هل ممكن العمليه العسكريه تؤدي الى
تقليص قدرات العسكريه للحوثيين و قوات
الرئيس علي عبد الله صالح بحيث انه يجبروا
على الجلوس على بقده المفاوضات على اعتبار
ان الخيار اللي بيتخيل البعض الاستسلام
الكامل غير وارد فهل ده وارد انه يجلسوا
من فائده المفاوضات وتعود الامور الى سابق
عهدها ويعود الرئيس
ا الهادي الى سده الحكم وتمشي الامور بمجر
الطبيعي وان كان هذا السيناريو سيناريو
غير متوقع لكن برض بقيه السيناريوهات كلها
سيناريوهات مفتوحه تاثيرها على السعوديه
واقتصادها وامنها تاثيرها على باقي دول
الخليج تاثيرها على الملاحه البحريه ماذا
لو تغير موقف الولايات المتحده اللي
ظاهريا هي تدعم السعوديه ودول التحالف في
حربها على اليمن ماذا لو ارادت السعوديه
معاقبه هذه الدول او الضغط عليها من خلال
الملف اليمني بانها ترفع اي ايد ايد او
الدعم الامريكي من عليهافي توجهات في
الولايات المتحده انها تنسحب تدريجيا من
منطقه الخليج خاصه مع تضاؤل احتياجها
للنفط الخليجي والنفط العربي يكون ايه
المصير ويكون ايه الملف ويكون ايه هي
التوابع لمسار الحرب في اليمن يا ترى ايه
اللي ممكن يحسن في دول الخليج لو زادت
الثقه بين ايران والولايات المتحده خصوصا
بعد ابرام الاتفاق النووي منذ عده اسابيع
بشكل نهائي اللي خلاص انه اصبحوا انه قررت
الايران انها تجمد ملف النووي في مقابل
رفع العقوبات اللي كل الناس يعرفوه على
مدار حوالي 10 سنوات ايه توابع الثقه التي
يمكن ان تكتسبها ايران
من خلال هذه الاتفاقيه ما قد يعطيها كرت
مفتوح او ضوء اخضر انها تعود الى المنطقه
بكامل قوتها ولياقتها ما تنسوش ان الحرب
في اليمن كانت احد التوابع
المباشره لهذا الاتفاق شعرت السعوديه ان
الولايات المتحده تخلت عنها
وباعت دول الخليج لصالح ايران فقررت هي
وباقي دول الخليج رفع شعار ما حك جلدك مثل
ظفرك فقررت انها تتدخل عسكريا في اليمن
بشكل مباشر لعده اسباب احدها اجهاد النفوذ
الايراني الذي يسعى
الى محاصرتها من الجنوب ده واحد من
الاسباب لكن تخيلوا بقى لو ادركت السعوديه
وباقي دول الخليج ان الولايات المتحده
اللي هي بتدعم حتى الان على الاقل نظريا
ودبلوماسيا تتخلى عنهم تماما ده ملف ملف
هيفضل المفتوح في 2016 واعتقد ان هذا
الملف سوف يحظى باهميه اكبر بكثير مما حظي
بها في 2015 في ملف
البحرين البحرين بلد بيعيش فوق صفيح ساخن
ما تنسوش ان في 2000 في مارس 2 و1 اضطرت
دول الخليج وعلى راسها السعوديه ان تتدخل
بقوات بشكل مباشر لحمايه الحكومه و الدوله
البحرينيه من اضطرابات رات دول الخليج
انها اضطرابات تم التخطيط لها من جانب
ايران للاستيلاء على البحرين وبرغم ان
المساله محل خلاف الا ان هذه الرؤيه
الخليجيه حتى هذا اليوم وبتعتمد ان ايران
لم تنسى ابدا اطمع في البحرين وبتعتمد
السعوديه وباقي دول الخليج ان طهران ترى
ان اسهل مدخل واهم مدخل بالنسبه ل نفوذها
الى دول الخليج من خلال البحرين اللي
بتعتبرها
ايران احدى اراضيها التاريخيه وكانت بتقول
انه البحرين الى طبعا البحرين استقلت سنه
71 باستفتاء عن ايران وايران بتعتقد وما
زال حتى الان على لسان بعض يعني
الاكاديميين او الاعلاميين مش المسؤولين
الرئيسيين ان بتعتبرها المحافظه ال 14 الى
لايران وانها كانت ممثله في البرلمان
الايراني لغايه منتصف الخمسينات ايه اللي
ممكن يحصل اذا تجددت الاضطرابات في
البحرين اللي بتواجهها دول الخليج بالمال
وبالدعم الاقتصادي وبالسلاح المباشر
بقوتها الموجوده في البحرين ده ملف كان
مفتوح في السنوات الاربعه وطبعا قبل
السنوات الاربعه انا بتكلم بعد الربيع
العربي ومفتوح من فترات طويله لكن هل يمكن
ان يتجدد بعد ان تتغير السياسه الايرانيه
بانها تصبح اكثر عدوانيه واكثر حضورا على
الساحه بعد الاتفاق التاريخي بينها وبين
الغرب فيما يتعلق باغلاق الملف النووي
لايران ده سؤال ثاني مفتوح في 2016 في ملف
ثالث مهم جدا بعيدا على المشرق العربي في
اتجاه المغرب العربي ما هو مصير الجزائر
في حاله ا وفاه الرئيس الجزائري الحالي
عبد العزيز بوتفليقه الرجل الذي يبلغ من
العمر ب 78 عام وجدد الانتخابات رغم مرضه
الشديد في 17 ابريل 2014 كانت الفتره
الرئاسيه الرابعه وطبعا كانت خبر تقدمه
للرئاسه جاء بعد فتره لان رجل كان شريد
المرض لكن كل اللي كانوا متابعين الامر
كان بيعرفوا كويس قوي انه لم يكن هناك
خيار للنظام في الجزائر ولا لبوتفليقة
لان خروج بوتفليقه من الحكم كان يعني الا
تنجو الجزائر من توابع الربيع العربي اللي
بدا في 2011 ماذا يمكن ان يحدث للجزائر
التي تعيش ايضا على صفيح ساخن في حاله
خروج بوتفليقه من المشر الجزائر بلد مهم
جدا الاحداث اللي فيها تؤثر على المغرب
تؤثر على تونس تؤثر على جيرانهم في الشمال
اوروبا قد تفتح
خروج بوتفليقه من
الصوره المجال لتصورات وسيناريوهات كثيره
بعضها متوقع وبعدها قد لا يتم توقعه ابدا
الثلاث سيناريوهات دول الثلاث ملفات دول
بخلاف الملفات المزمنه زي سوريا وداعش
والعراق ملف الاكراد ملف الاكراد ده كذلك
ملف شديد الاهميه حظي باهميه شديده برضو
من بعد 201
وخصوصا
مع الاحداث في
سوريا برض من 2011 بعد ثورات الربيع
العربي مع الضعف العراقي الشريف ايه اللي
ممكن يحصل لسلامه الدوله التركيه اذا قرر
اذا اعطت الاحداث القائمه قوه اكبر
للاكراد بحيث جددت طموحهم في طموحهم في
الاستقلال واقامه دوله خصوصا اذا حظيت
ببعض الدعم من العالم الغربي ايه اللي
ممكن يحصل لسلامه الدوله التركيه اللي
بتضم على اراضيها ملايين الاكراد ده سؤال
تاني
قد يكون محل اهتمام وقد يكون سيناريو
مطروح في 2016 ويستحق الاهتمام سنارات
كتيره ممكن تكون مطروحه في
2016 بعضها نتوقعه وبعضها قد ياتي من حيث
لا نعلم في 2 سبعه خرج علينا عالم امريكي
من اصل لبناني هو نسيم طالب نسيم نقولا
طالب هو عالم في الرياضات الرياضه
الماليه وراجل بتاع مشتقات ماليه في سوق
المال
واقتصادي طبعا الراجل خرج علينا بنظريه
تستحق الاهتمام وممكن تبقى دي صله باللي
احنا بنتكلم عليه خرج علينا بكتاب سماه
البجعه السوداء او ذا بلاك سون ايه البجعه
السوداء دي خلاصه الكتاب بيقول ايه انه
الاحداث الكبيره في التاريخ لا يمكن ابدا
توقع يعني تقدر تتوقع في نظريه بتقول ان
هيستري ريبيت سلف او التاريخ بيكرر نفسه
هو رايه ان التاريخ بيكرر نفسه او الاحداث
التي يمكن توقعها دي الاحداث العاديه ان
الاحداث اللي اما تاثيرها محدود او لا
تغير مجرى التاريخ اما الاحداث الكبرى
اللي بتغير وجه التاريخ من اليمين الى
اليسار او من اليسار الى اليمين فهي من
عند الله يصعب جدا على الانسان ان يتوقع
وادى امثله كتيره في كتابه اللي هو البجعه
السوداء بالحرب العالميه الاولى قبل الحرب
العالميه الاولى لم يكن احد ابدا حتى
بدايه عام
1914 يتوقع اندلاع حرب كبرى تكون اطرافها
بريطانيا والمانيا او بريطانيا والمانيا
يعني دول المحور ودول الح حلفاء ابدا وكان
في عالم ا شهير بيحظ باحترام كبير في
بريطانيا اسمه نورمان اجل كان كتاباته
مؤثره جدا في اوروبا وكان بيستبح تماما ان
تقود ان تقوم اي حرب في اوروبا وحرب ضخمه
لان المصالح التجاريه بين كل الاطراف
والقوى الاساسيه شريده التشابك وكل الدول
مستفيده من هذا التشابك التجاري فضلا ان
العولمه بمعيار 1914 كانت وصلت الى مداها
التليفون والتلي جراف والقطار اللي هو
بالبخار دوت فكان بيعتقد انه سبل التواصل
وسبل التفاهم مع الدول ومصالحها اكبر
بكثير من ممكن تعرض العالم كبيره بحيث
انها تحول دون اندلاع صراع كبير خلال شهور
رغم ان كل الناس كان
يعني يعني مرتاح الى هذه التصور اندلعت
الحرب العالميه الاولى اللي راحب ضحيتها
ملايين الناس دون ان يتوقعها احد ثم ادت
بعد ذلك الى الحرب العالميه الثانيه وغيرت
تاريخ العالم كله قص على كده احداث كتيره
غيرت العالم اكتشاف الانترنت لم يكن احد
يتوقعه الازمه الماليه العالميه اللي بدات
في 2007 و2008 وصلتنا احنا في المنطقه في
2009 الكارثه الماليه اللي بدات في
الولايات المتحده وشملت العالم ولم يتعافى
منها العالم حتى الان لم يكن احد ابدا
يتوقع لم يكن احد ابدا يتوقع في 2007
اندلاع ازمه ماليه تؤدي لاختفاء بنوك
عملاقه زي ليمن براذرز خلال ايام وتتبخر
اصول ومدخرات دول مش بس افراد الاحداث في
العالم العربي كثير منها بيخضع لهذه
النظريه نظريه البجعه السودا بل اكثر من
العالم الغربي بحكم ان الشفافيه قليله وان
الامور عندنا يعني مرتبكه لا احداث ثورات
الربيع العربي كانت متوقعه او حتى لم تكن
تاثيرها الكبير غير متوقع بهذا الحجم
وتقدر تاخد احداث كثيره في العالم العربي
تحط عليها علامات استفهام لم يكن احد ابدا
يتوقع لا في العالم العربي ولا خارج
العالم العربي لم يكن احد ابدا حتى يتوقع
قبل يونيو 2014 انه جماعات المقاومه
العاديه او الجماعات سواء كانت جماعات
مقاومه وطنيه او جماعات
مقاومه مذهبيه او طائفيه تتحول او يخرج من
بين صفوفها جماعه اسمها داعش حتى وزير
الدفاع الامريكي السابق تشاك هيجل قال
كلام خطير جدا من
حوالي اسبوعين يمكن في 17 او 19 ديسمبر
الماضي قال في حوار ليه في تصريحات ليه
لصحف امريكيه ان انا وانا بتابع ده هو
بيتكلم على لسانه وانا بتابع الاحداث في
ذلك الوقت كنت ببلغ البيت الابيض وكل
المسؤولين هناك شيء غريب شيء لم نعهده من
قبل ولكنهم سخروا من الفكره يبدو برض انه
هو بنظريه البجعه السودا لم يكن يتوقع احد
ظهور جماعه بحجم داعش توابع ظهور داعش حتى
الان في 2015 وفي 2016 عليه علاه استفهام
عمليات الازاحه التغير الديمغرافي السكاني
اللي ممكن يؤدي لانفجار في لبنان نتيجه
تغير التركيبه السكانيه الهجرات الجماعيه
اللي بقت على راس ازمات اوروبا كل دي امور
ما كانتش متوقعه في
2015 واثارها غير متوقعه في
2016 بالمناسبه هو سماها نظريه البجعه
السودا لانه كان طوال القرن ال 17
الاوروبيين بيعتقدوا انه كل البجع لازم
يكون ابيض ومستحيل تكون فيه بجعه سودا
واستمر الاعتقاد ده اكثر من 100 سنه لغايه
ما اكتشفوا بالصدفه بجعه بيضا ا بجعه سودا
في استراليا فكان ده تعبير يعني على انه
المستحيل ممكن يحصل والمستحيل ممكن يحصل
في 2016 زي ما حصل في سنين كتيره عندنا
ملفات كتيره قد تحمل الينا مفاجات ساره او
غير ساره لكن كمان بحكم نظريه البجعه
السودا قد ياتينا السيء او الخير من حيث
لا نعلم ولا نحتسب نتمنى من الله سبحانه
وتعالى ان يكون عام طيب علينا وعلى كل
الامه العربيه والامه الاسلاميه وكل
العالم اشكركم القاكم في حلقات اخرى ان
شاء الله نحاول فيها قراءه المستقبل
وملفات المنطقه والى القاكم باذن الله